I'm David I'm a real estate developer
here in Charlotte it's my girlfriend
Willow this is our crib met online
Happy anniversary baby
[Music]
he still thinks it's too good to be true
and I'm like I'm just I'm just I'm just
here existing try to figure out how much
of my closet I'm giving up most likely a
bunch this is going to be mine and this
is gonna be mine and this is gonna be
his
when I first met him I didn't ask you
how old you were I didn't really ask you
what you did I didn't want to really
know anything I didn't want to be
influenced by anything outside I just
wanted to like know him as a person
first I was a little concerned about her
age because I was like you're really
young I have a baby face thank you
[Music]
first on the wall
and from there it's been constant
constant non-stop for the last 90 days
this is her favorite place
oh I don't even ask her no he does not
he acts like a 15 year old boy I get B12
energy shots I do for real yeah to keep
up life literally is not fast enough for
me we've been in the Bahamas like three
times in Punta Cana in Las Vegas twice
in West Virginia twice or three times it
took me to see the Backstreet Boys
Backstreets back all right growing up I
was like three four five like listening
to the Backstreet Boys and I was old
enough to go to a concert in public
people never really say anything at all
but on social media people like to call
me a gold digger some people say I'm
just a sugar daddy but oh they're so
cute with your dad oh it was nice you
went to Vegas with your grandpa and what
you're doing is sick and
I'm doing this right now because I make
money and I have to make money to feed
my family so as long as it makes me
money I will come on here and I will say
this is a sickness
it is deviant therefore we don't want it
but the moment is not profitable huh I
will never say any of this out in public
again yeah well it's profitable for her
could be what to be sick
absolutely yes yes there are many things
that are profitable in this world oh
it's profitable for him too just
profitable to go out the street and open
your bum hole for the people who are
willing to pray it doesn't mean it's a
good idea huh I take stuff personally so
I'm like
uh look at this person's being mean to
everyone facing judgment from haters the
haters that's how we live by it he could
keep saying
I was influenced a lot by Rihanna in my
teen years so I have a fit mentality
my family has been really really
supportive of our whole relationship and
her mother's like I'm convinced you all
knew each other in a prior life
but really she goes I've never seen my
daughter smile and be this happy okay
being serious I don't care that these
two want to do this and that's fine the
parents being on with it is [ __ ]
weird anytime your daughter's dating
somebody who's older than you as a
parent that should raise some [ __ ]
red flags yes he is actually older than
her even if it was my son okay and I'm
in my 40s and he dings he's 20 he's
dating somebody in their 50s I might
have a long-ass conversation I won't be
like oh my God this is so sweet and cute
nah Nabi that's crazy the thought yo be
that's crazy peep game this girl could
be my daughter
yes
and this guy could be my dad
no now
I get yes no
absolutely [ __ ] not I'm listen she
wants to go date him they want that's
fine they're grown adults but the
parents being dope went down with this
are thinking like that's really weird to
me
yeah she's terrified of the light bro
look
so this young lady is a very special
person in my life she's around my place
maybe three to four times a week we get
up to a lot of Mischief playing around
all kinds of goofy things at first she
was terrified you can see uh she was
scared of the light she didn't
understand what was going on but she got
to know it a little bit and get used to
it
oh
see
what do you think
there you go she's realizing it's fine
[Laughter]
the Galaxy projector will light up your
room and make you think that you're in
outer space with countless stars that
nebulize surrounding you you want me to
close the light
of course so we close this boom
Sushi come take your power
when I'm working when I'm home I spend
so much time editing it's nice to be
able to just switch up the lights that
feel completely different just based off
of one click of the button even using
the well integrated app where you can
change the lights based off whatever
mood you're going through so whether
you're getting romantic whether you're
having fun whether you just want to get
intensive and start thinking a little
bit differently the Galaxy projector is
a great way for you to change your room
without having to change it too much you
feel me right now today there's a cyber
monday sale using our Link in the
description below okay you get 50 off up
to sixty dollars in savings on the
Galaxy projector right now don't waste
any time click the link in the
description below I tell all my friends
it's way actually don't actually do not
give me any crap
you look beautiful as always too thank
you
we're celebrating the big three months
that's good it has been three months now
three months three months of something
there you go you remember our trip to
tuna brought my beautiful model my
little Willow and uh you know I was a
little nervous bringing her out you know
bringing her over to meet y'all
honestly what y'all think I mean there's
a big age difference
but who cares nowadays you know if you
guys love each other and you're happy
together then I'll you know go for it
I'm gonna be dead honest when I saw her
with you I thought she's way too pretty
for you haven't you met
you're just as sweet then as as these
are the time people say all this [ __ ]
and the moment they get behind that door
and they start heading home it's like
can you believe this [ __ ] loser I
hate that you want a new hot piece of
ass that's fine but don't break
protocols Steve
keep her [ __ ] private and have a
regular sugar baby instead of doing all
this dumb [ __ ] in public how do you
think it's going to look at our company
board meetings you [ __ ] lose our
place I feel like I mean like they're
saying all this nice stuff because it's
for the cameras it's PR but if you're
being honest
you're looking and you're judging yeah
you are
you are because here's the thing
everyone's doing this like oh my God I
love him for a soul but for
I'll be okay she noticed him and she was
open to him because he was rich and
famous if I see a poor woman do this
with a really older man I'll start
thinking differently okay but generally
all these young women who go for these
supremely older men do it because these
guys are really affluent and well-off
just a coincidence maybe it's a
coincidence
Maybe
but if she goes on dates another 60 year
old who's bored afterwards after this
one die I'll shut my mouth still a
coincidence
but I don't believe it and it's fine
there's nothing wrong with that Dynamic
there's nothing wrong with woman wanting
to be with a man because he's absolutely
rich and you know he's not a bad looking
old man like he's doing this thing he's
keeping up he's taking his trt shout
outs to him
and there's nothing wrong with him
wanting a younger woman
is just that we need to not lie about
what it is you go after her because she
wants you for your wealth and your money
and she's youthful she's in her prime
years or whatever and you want him
because he's got all that money and he's
probably been able to accumulate it
because he's much older
it's not crazy
but people like oh my God I'm not yes
you are and yes he is and it's okay it's
fine if y'all y'all happy with that yeah
cast y'all agreement exactly just as
sweet then as as you are now so no I
mean you are you're a genuine person and
you're very compatible this has been an
amazing connection so we have a lot in
common I'm born February 2nd she's
February 3rd
because of astrology I don't fit
actually this dude this this dude is is
smelling his old farts
um well he's smelling his own farts he's
doing his whole romantic lovey-dovey
hippie [ __ ] I would have been much
more like you ain't get it if he's just
like listen you know yeah it's fun but
this dude seems like the kind of dude
you could fleece for money quite easily
because he's getting Enchanted by a
spell
and her favorite number is like 23 and
so I'm second she's the third so there's
a lot and we constantly see two three
everywhere it's crazy I mean you are
gonna come to the wedding right if that
were to happen where would it be y'all
want to do it here we're gonna get a
private jet to make everyone in Italy
who's we
oh wait wait just just give me two
seconds I just get to that my girl who's
we
I don't think you heard her correctly
she didn't say we she went oh we good
[Laughter]
she said
[Music]
burning
[Music]
oh wait
that's what if you guys don't ask
Ghostface Killer with Mark Ronson
all-time classic rap song one of my
favorite definitely going to listen
go tell me what y'all think leave a
comment please put me here yo you play
that song that [ __ ] that should get me
popping we want a dog and this is I want
a dog or like an ocelot or something I
don't know what's a mass a lot just
trust me
no
turn that [ __ ] off I've seen enough turn
that [ __ ] off turn that whole [ __ ] off
he's talking about oh we don't know we
want an ocelot so we're gonna do uh
we're gonna fly people to Italy on a
private jet girl you are a hundred
percent see you don't want to say it
because it sounds bad whenever we say it
sounds bad but actually it actually is
what it is okay you are everything that
it is and he's a sugar that if he
provides you with an ocelot
which I believe that in some places is
an Indigent an endangered species
it's the brother of Solid Snake the
Metal Gear Solid absolutely yes that's
all I keep thinking about it yes I hear
ocelot and I think of revolvers and
[ __ ] getting shot with a mustache yeah
yeah snake
we meet again friend
oh
[Music]
I've definitely dated older men before
they've learned already and you don't
have to babysit them you're courteous
rap you said what you said you said you
said men before say what you said she 23
and she on that grind
guess what how are you 23 and you dated
older men my God you are sugar my God
you are what you are yes ma'am I ain't
saying she's a gold digger but she ain't
gonna win with no broke
well fellas
do not take care of a lady they open the
car door pull the chair out stand up
when you get to the table and it's nice
we're getting ready to go to our
anniversary dinner have a little
anniversary gift bam we have the private
wine cellar tonight so I'm excited I
have no idea what that means but I'm
ready to find out
[Music]
places
I know it's amazing like going to
McDonald's at this point we know we know
what we're gonna get a bottle of the
Imperials we usually get anyone happy
anniversary to us happy anniversary
to us
another present has it been the best 90
days ever yeah it has actually what did
you give me
[Music]
thank you
they go with your diamond necklace
yeah look at that diamonds are
ghostbusters I treat her like a queen I
pull her chair out I stand up when she
stands up you did not pull my chair out
today well didn't the manager or
somebody I mean no
[Music]
yeah
okay
oh it's one of them people she got more
weddings fed um
you know there's better brands
of champagne than that
like it's not in the price and the
Allure you know you hear about Don P and
you hear about Moet but there's other
champagne that are actually better
Noir better
but less pricey but still better you you
not use everything bro huh money's
everything
she is old enough to drink yeah I am I
even brought her passport just in case
dated pretty girls before but there
wasn't a connection this was a
connection a real connection and she
makes me happy so
what am I gonna do love me love you feed
you take care of you
what happened at the end there
so it is a connection so what am I gonna
do love me feed you
hey man so basically a sugar daddy Jesus
Christ Hey listen listen listen he made
all his money if he wants to do that now
good for him you but let's call it
[ __ ] go with the [ __ ] goat okay
and here's a little stop it's a flathead
kids and I'm getting my 60s once I get
divorced my life God forbid last thing I
want to do is be hanging around a 20
year old embarrassing my own kids in my
family like Ah that's just cringy to me
no I don't think he has kids and [ __ ]
I'd be shocked if he did
but I could be wrong maybe you got a
vasectomy and whatever but watching it
was interesting she's clearly and it's
okay like here's the thing about I don't
care just don't lie about what you're
there for yeah that's fine that's a
profession there's nothing wrong with it
it's a professional I've dated a lot of
older guys at 23 boo boo [ __ ] you gotta
type and they not old and broke they owe
them what
Rich oh way
we know what it is it's cool it's okay
it's okay it's okay
dating my grant my father gold digging
my daughter's not doing my job it's the
best job because you don't get to pay
taxes she don't work she don't pay taxes
it's great you you you you did good your
daughter dated your dad I know